[Music]  i love my life  i love you so much gary i'll never  forget the day we met  hello little snail what's your name gary  huh  do you want to be friends me  too gary i'm home  gary bear gary  oh gary have you seen gary no nope  nope gary's been snail mapped  [Music]  get ready for the ultimate rescue  mission  you're fired danny trejo snoop dogg  tiffany haddish seriously i'm  floundering up here  and keanu reeves call me sage  i'm made out of sage and i am a sage so  it works out pretty well  see how the gang all met  [Music]  little dude and experience spongebob's  biggest adventure ever  sorry saves them patrick what are you  doing  free food  the all-new spongebob movie sponge on  the run premiering march 4th  rented from these digital stores also  streaming on paramount plus